the Ebola virus is moving south and a
bustling city of more than a million
lies directly in its path
it's called Goma and the people who live
here are afraid
are you worried as your family worried
Marja popular syrup ed mm illicitly take
up a humanitarian group NSF are digging
in and building up with a brand new
Ebola treatment center on the outskirts
of town they don't want to frighten
residents but they need to prepare and
they'll have 72 beds here when they're
finished
we followed the epidemic since the
beginning going south Yoma is a big city
where people trouble it's likely that
this can be the next one and it takes
one person to travel and that's it
government officials can't stop people
with the virus from traveling to Goma so
they have to stop them from infecting
others when they're here surveillance
teams now hunt for residents who've been
exposed it's a big operation the
surveillance teams have tracked down 137
people who've been in direct contact
with a victim of Ebola but they can't
stop there they've also got to track
down the people who've been in contact
with the direct contacts because that's
how the infection works it's a
logistical nightmare they've got plenty
of expertise but there's only so much
they can do I spoke to the man in charge
is an Ebola outbreak in this city
inevitable probable ammonia
the prettiest lot okapis corrected in
small Yonkers was a vault under control
only for the shock of one Malad partying
a musician that's just like a pastor who
managed to avoid the mandatory
temperature checks as he traveled to
Goma last week when the churchmen was
discovered at this clinic
he was so ill there was nothing health
workers could do to save him the
authorities are looking for anyone who
may have approached him and they're
offering each one twenty kilograms of
food that way they're less likely to
travel around and spread the virus if
they have it
an epidemic in this city would be
catastrophic and it's something the
government and their partners must try
to prevent but the Ebola virus is almost
certainly here John Sparkes Sky News in
Goma